we are very excited about our next
guests why because it's a very talented
Connie Britton she is known for roles in
Friday Night Lights yes Nashville oh I
love that show season one of the White
Lotus loved her in that too now she
stars in the new Apple TV plus series
it's called dear Edward it tells a
fictional story about a little boy named
Edward was the only Survivor of a plane
crash Britain plays a wealthy woman her
name is Dede Cameron whose husband dies
in the accident in this clip from before
the crash she meets her daughter for a
very special birthday meal at one of
their favorite restaurants
Omega you ladies something to get
started with oh yes we always start with
the oh such a caveat please and the foie
gras sorry Ducks I'm salivating are you
salivating and a bottle of Crystal yes
and a bottle of Cristal we've been
sneaking it since she was 18 and they
don't mind here and I'm gonna pretend I
didn't hear that um
thank you he's so cute oh my God I love
him you could date him are you okay I
mean I don't know do you think he's gay
he works in the theater or you're gay I
don't know I'm sorry that's so rude you
can be gay straight whatever honey I
don't care you be okay yes let's change
this yeah hi hi
different kind of mom a different kind
of mom Friday Night Lights though I know
what kind of mom what kind of mom yes
yes that's collecting and she joins us
first on CBS mornings clearly you're
very irritating to your daughter there
and I I think this is a fun nugget about
you in this particular role it says you
turn to the cast of New Jersey's Real
Housewives of New Jersey for some
inspiration I don't know was it Teresa
was it Melissa oh clearly oh no I don't
know was it Dolores what are you looking
for it was an amalgam of them all
beautiful ladies you know I just wanted
to kind of get I I love the idea of
somebody that we see from the outside
what we have these ideas about and I'm
like okay I want to get underneath that
like who are they really yeah so I
thought that was is a fun place to start
with this character but it reunites you
with the showrunner it must be nice to
be wanted as Tony was saying about
Friday Night Lights it re it reunites
you and Jason again together and he said
he thought about you for this role in
particular and when you read the role
you thought yeah this is me I know I
want this I was so surprised especially
because he was from Friday Night Lights
and this character is so different from
Tammy Taylor but I love that I love that
he had a vision for that and for me and
for us coming back together and it was
just a joy it was so much fun there's
some tough stuff in here I mean it's not
giving away too much to say that your
character loses her husband in this
plane crash is at the center of the
story and uh you're in a grief support
group and part of it did you have to
learn things and about grief yourself in
order to get into that role well I've
had experience with grief and but again
everybody's experience is individual but
I think what's great about this show and
what I was able to tap into playing this
character is that there is a really
Primal Universal aspect to grief we all
experience grief you cannot go through
life without experiencing loss and pain
and grief and that is something that is
connective tissue for all of us as human
beings which is why I think people are
going to love this show and to that
point you were telling me in the Green
Room you're at a point in your career
now where you want your roles to in some
way help reflect to viewers at home what
is happening in the world can you
expound on that well I I think that we
are and we may not even realize it but I
think that as a culture we're
experiencing Collective grief because
we're because of this pandemic we've
been going through because of the
climate crisis there is global grief
happening on a very major level and we
don't necessarily have the language for
that and and so my hope is with this
show that people are going to recognize
themselves even though these characters
are going through different experiences
there's something that's going to
connect and make people feel seen and
then make them feel like oh I can look
at this I can find a way to talk about
grief in my own experience in my own
life I think you raised such a good
point because I think we are going
through so much as a society I don't
think we even realize how heavy times
are yeah because we don't often drill
down on it and I think sometimes you
need to get through grief it in however
it shows itself with humor so this as
sad as this show is and I'm getting on a
plane later today so I'm totally freaked
out because I'm a nervous flyer so I'm
like ah but as as tough as the show is
it's not a Sad Sack show no no it's not
something that's going to bring you down
all the story lines are great all the
characters are going through something
well first of all for me my in my
experience of grief personally the thing
that pulled me out of it the thing that
I remember the most is the humor the
people that surround me in my life that
came in and brought laughter and
reminded me of light you know and so
with this character I really wanted to
make sure that she brought the humor to
the show in some ways and because I
think that that's an important aspect
when we're looking at the pain of loss
and so I I think people are going to
come away watching the show I don't want
people to think oh I can't watch that
show it's going to make me too depressed
tonight I very well are going to come
away and feel actually uplifted I love
doing White Lotus yeah are you coming
back I was going to tuck in a question
some fans think you are that's the big
question
this is a new show you can break some
news Connie you have an agent working on
that right now I mean what's happening
gosh you know what I adore Mike White I
think he is a brilliant genius I I just
will always work with him in any
capacity and okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
take that as a yes Connie Britton thank
you dear Edward is available to stream
right now on Apple TV plus chances are
you have it on your phone you really do